an essential quality that a leader needs
to have for social change I think a
vision they have to know what they want
to change too it's not sufficient to
simply say that what is is insufficient
you
I have several actually but uh
it applies to children I think Miriam
right Elliman who heads the Children's
Defense Fund she clearly saw that there
was a need for more efforts and more
policy more research and more resources
geared towards the betterment of all
children and she dedicated her life to
making that happen and started a
fabulous organization that does just
that
you
when I realize that social just
was a vision I think I always felt that
way I probably began to work to create
it a couple of years as a professor I
began doing some work with the Ford
Foundation and that exposed me to a
broader vision of the world and sort of
possibilities and moving out of what is
in to what can be out of what I call
descriptive ethics into prescriptive
ethics and and that was sort of that was
the beginning of it and as you can
imagine once you get on that train it's
hard to get off
you
I think what does work is the shifting
of resources and shifting a power there
are multiple forms of capital there's
economic capital which philanthropy
obviously is very much invested in a
part of but there's also social capital
and cultural capital and human capital
and in a capitalist society you know all
that is tied to money and I think that's
something that philanthropy does is it
is a very good job of sort of shifting
that or broadening that what I think
philanthropy doesn't always do as good
of a job of is imposing its own agenda
on to people and quite often it feels
like it's actually making a difference
when if you were to show up to a bunch
of poor people and say hey here's a
check for fifty thousand dollars if you
do X Y or Z don't you think it's a great
idea of course we're going to say it's a
great idea but it may not be something
that they want it may not be something
is actually benefit them but it makes
the philanthropist feel good
you
I purpose myself to partner with those
and be in the presence of those who are
doing the same thing and when you see
the product of it the process is a
little bit easier students would rather
watch a big thing video then sit and
read along page of text in a textbook
they have an opportunity to get the
information that they wouldn't
necessarily otherwise have we're using
the technologies to connect to learn
students can participate by using the
internet to their advantage